so for both of you if someone has
actually never seen anything that you've
done before what is the first thing you
want them watching and why i don't care
yeah that's the whole idea and the thing
is that there's certain things i might
be more proud of than other things but
at the same time
we kind of enter this world always to
make the best possible film in history
we will never achieve it but that's the
goal
um for different reasons i'm proud of
everything and and people can start
wherever and they might get surprised
later on and if they do it in reverse
order the same will happen
i like that answer i'm gonna
side with him too i like that um
one of the things about these movies is
that they're these like they're huge
they're massive the scale and scope the
vfx everything about it what do you
think for fans of this franchise what do
you think might surprise someone to
learn about the actual making of this
movie uh it was surprising i i saw the
movie a month ago and i didn't really
know what the movie had looked like
because there was a lot of just doing
magic and then it's like and then the
teacups go up and around
a lot of times uh you you have
people kind of telling you what you're
seeing in your mind and you're just
imagining it and then you see it like
over a year later i think that process
was really amazing
and i think that another thing that will
surprise people is that
there is we use green screen but
not as much as people believe
these sets are built they build giant
sets you know you have you can walk up
this close and touch it and you can't i
mean it looks real it is real
um so i think people would be amazed of
how much is actually being built and
it's really there for us to see
uh what i've spoken to a lot of casts
and some of them like to hang out offset
they go for drinks they you know
text chains what was it like offset for
you guys in terms of did you guys get to
go for drinks together was it or because
of covid was it just a completely
different experience
yeah i mean the the coveted music was
playing right so so that put a limit to
a lot of very loud yeah yeah
yeah we didn't it was just sort of like
you wrapped and we all kind of shot in
these pods to kind of keep everybody
safe and and not being exposed they're
really just it was it felt like we were
in a bubble you would work
and and come and go home and work and go
home we were really in the height of the
pandemic um when we shot this film
if your if your character from this
movie were to walk into starbucks what
are they ordering as their
drink i think i think he's something
he's an aesthetic this guy he would
probably walk into a starbucks and ask
for a glass of water oh that's really
cool yeah yeah i'm gonna go just like a
mocha i'm gonna go with a mocha
um
it tastes good and she's
a mocha woman i don't know i'll go with
a mocha
you like it right yeah i love it
uh who was the fastest out of their
trailer to set and who was the one that
you were always waiting on
oh that's funny
i don't think we're waiting on anybody
no no that's a big problem if you're
just waiting waiting on somebody but i
do know eddie eddie would go home pretty
fast because he was usually first
first and last like he had the longest
amount of days i feel like yeah but he
will also be on set
the whole day one time bang totally
before everybody else totally
who was the person who actually made you
laugh the most
on set while filming was there someone
that's like a real jokester
oh dan dan fogler for sure callum turner
is really funny
both both of those guys for me i yeah we
shot a scene that was taking place on
the plateau
for
a few weeks the same scene
and i was standing very close to oliver
and uh he is a prankster he's funny yeah
um what is the most amount of takes that
you did on this movie for what scene or
sequence and why why was it so many
takes
yeah i did this one uh fight sequence um
that took place in bhutan and uh i just
read uh i just kept laughing um
callum and i because we had to do this
technical slow turn and i just remember
laughing and we literally had to do it
50 times i think
that would be the reason why you have to
you know just laughing yeah yeah
sometimes once you that does the trick
sometimes yeah sometimes once you
realize something's funny in the scene
you just kind of can't stop and so it
was one of those where we had to be like
sorry sorry i promise we're professional
but it was just
did you wish to just have a green screen
here totally just green screen just blur
this over you know i would say i mean
that that scene we talked about in good
friends yeah a big big scene just i
think we shot it for a month or
something well
and the reason why that was it was very
long and very elaborate seeing a lot of
things a lot of dramatic things happened
and we had cameras flying around
crisscrossing so
so that was that was that same was cool
actually i just remembered
i we had this camera on a wire
was it called the spider camera i i
don't remember it was kind of like what
they use on football games where you can
yeah
run around go all the way around and so
people we would be doing the scene all
the way through and it was a really long
scene but you would hear this rear sort
of like a drone like
yeah
program the timing yeah and to our
acting so we had to kind of dance with
the camera they would be programmed for
nine minutes yeah yeah
yeah but it looks great in the final
product yeah oh it looked amazing
yeah um what is it like actually
practicing with a wand to get ready to
use a wand in one of these movies are
they giving you some sort of like
training video like are they saying look
at the other harry potter movies and say
you know what i mean what does it
actually look like they give you this
like video and it's like hi i'm tom
felton and i'm here to talk to you about
my trick uh i'm i'm gonna say i was
doing the juan work with my wands from
the noble collection uh long before i
got this job offer so it was really nice
to be able to do this and be paid for it
like that was really nice as opposed to
just kind of doing this on my own and
not and not being paid for it and
we worked with this really great
movement coach um i did before the movie
her name was alex reynolds and she was
really lovely with helping us with the
wand work it was you do get sore from it
too which was very surprising
yeah it's like an extension of your arm
it's like a mix of being a conductor and
or
or fencing with a very fine french
floret
and you find your own style anyway so
they're not telling you how to do it you
figure out how your character might hold
it is it is it light or is it powerful
oh it's a good mix how did you find you
did did your like how does grindelwald
do it not too fancy very specific but
and um with
firm endings you know wow yeah strong
mines was i felt like her match she's
very hard driven yolali and i felt like
it was coming from inward
and so i would i wasn't just doing this
all the time but i felt like her magic
came from the ground from the earth and
then i would try and send it out and
transform an extension yeah yeah but
that was the thing that didn't tell us
that right jessica would come up with
that idea and then they would work on it
right and actually what kind of bougies
that she did kind of she had a pinky up
she did yeah she's kind of bougie so she
just went i might have that one yeah a
little bit
it's actually nice though because uh the
way that uh david would let you sort of
[ __ ] like uh add this to your character
like even though it's this huge movie uh
you get to you know add your imprint to
it
sure absolutely that was what was nice
for me for working with david was like
he trusted us a lot of the time to fill
in the blanks about the character and
that was really lovely especially on a
movie that came with so much lore in
this wizarding world and so much you
know outside pressure
um i i felt like it was nice to feel
trusted with bringing life to lally it's
really nice
i know that you guys obviously wouldn't
have taken home anything from set
because you know you're not supposed to
do that but hypothetically what did you
borrow with every intention of bringing
it back
oh my definitely my wand that's that's
the one i want really bad but what did
you really take is that what you asked
what did what is hypothetically in your
home right now
that you know
do you have anything
but this is the thing hypothetically i
have to want right
yeah
but there was also tricky because they
had at least five people making sure
that the wands were returned
there's like a briefcase i tell you
we've tried everything on the sleeve
down the back of the neck everywhere
they found it every time yeah it's
interesting like when you're making the
movie though at any point are you saying
to them i would really like to take home
the wand like is it awesome i did that a
lot actually no i i really played a long
game i knew i would just ask for things
and they would be like no
no
no and even when i asked eddie i said
have you even gotten a briefcase and
he's like no no it's like top secret
like they lock it away for the next film
oh here's what you're going to do next
what are you doing
ask for a billion dollars right and then
no right ask for 100 million and then
keep going and find okay can i get the
wand at least
yeah okay yeah i'll do that next time
definitely so it's like can i have that
yeah exactly can i have that
no
um on that i gotta stop i'm just gonna
say again congrats and i hope it's a
huge hit for you guys
thank you thank you thanks
you